AFGHANISTAN.
PRESIDENT BIDEN WILL ADDRESS THE
NATION ON WHAT HAS BEEN CALLED
AMERICA'S LONGEST WAR.
THE TALIBAN IS IN FULL CONTROL.
YOU CAN SEE IT IN VIDEOS.
JUST MOMENTS AFTER THE U.S.
LEFT, THE TALIBAN ENTERED THE
HANGAR CHECKING OUT THE
HELICOPTER ANDS OTHER EQUIPMENT
LEFT BEHIND.
ARMY MAJOR CHRIS DONOHUE, THE
LAST TO BOARD THE C-17 FLIGHT.
THIS IS THE LAST U.S. SOLDIER TO
LEAVE AFGHANISTAN.
WE WILL HEAR FROM THE PENTAGON
IN JUST A MOMENT.
>> THIS MORNING WE ARE ALSO
SEEING THE IMPACT OF HURRICANE
IDA AFTER MORE THAN A MILLION
HOMES AND BUSINESSES IN THREE
STATES DOWN SOUTH ARE STILL
WITHOUT POWER.
AND IT COULD BE FOR WEEKS BEFORE
THAT POWER IS RESTORED.
THE STORM LEFT A TRAIL OF
DESTRUCTION IN LOUISIANA AND
MISSISSIPPI, AND NOW COMES THE
SCORCHING HEAT WITH NO POWER.
TEMPERATURES COULD HIT 103
DEGREES TODAY.
OVERNIGHT, TWO PEOPLE WERE
KILLED WHEN FLOODS WASHED OUT A
MAJOR ROADWAY BETWEEN
MISSISSIPPI AND LOUISIANA.
>> FIRST, AFGHANISTAN, THE
CHALLENGES STILL AHEAD, AND THE
LEGACY OF WHAT HAS BEEN LEFT
BEHIND.
JOINING ME NOW IS PENTAGON PRESS
SECRETARY JOHN KIRBY.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
YOU KNOW, I'M COGNIZANT OF THE
FACT THAT YOU SPENT YOUR LIFE IN
PUBLIC SERVICE, A BIG CHUNK OF
IT IN THE MILITARY.
WHAT'S IT LIKE FOR YOU TO WAKE
UP THIS MORNING AND AFTER 20
YEARS, FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 20
YEARS, TO HAVE NO U.S. TROOPS IN
AFGHANISTAN?
>> YEAH, I THINK WE'RE ALL STILL
PROCESSING THAT, JOHN, TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT FOR TWO
DECADES WE'VE ALL BEEN CONNECTED
TO, WITHOUT QUESTION.
AND I THINK IT'S GOING TO TAKE
TIME FOR EVERY VETERAN TO SORT
OF PROCESS THIS ON THEIR OWN.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS HERE AT
THE PENTAGON THERE'S A MIXTURE
OF RELIEF WE WERE ABLE TO GET
EVERYBODY OUT SAFELY IN THOSE
LAST FEW HOURS, ALL THE LAST
REMAINING 800 TROOPS, AND WE
WERE ABLE TO EVACUATE 600
AMERICANS, 123,000 TOTAL PEOPLE
OUT.
THERE'S CONCERN, OBVIOUSLY, OVER
THE ONES WE COULDN'T GET OUT.
THAT TIME AND SPACE AND THE
SECURITY THREAT SIMPLY WOULDN'T
ALLOW US TO REACH.
ALTHOUGH WE DON'T THINK THE
NUMBERS ARE LARGE, WE ARE
OBVIOUSLY CONCERNED ABOUT OUR
FRIENDS, ALLIES AND AMERICAN
CITIZENS THAT ARE THERE.
>> I WANT TO COME BACK TO THE
100 OR 200 AMERICANS WHO MIGHT
BE THERE.
FIRST, THE PICTURE WE'VE BEEN
SHOWING FROM THE L.A. TIMES, THE
TALIBAN WALKEDING THROUGH THE
HANGAR, FULLY ARMED TALIBAN
WEARING WHAT LOOKED TO BE
AMERICAN GEAR LOOKING AT
AMERICAN EQUIPMENT.
I WONDER WHAT THESE IMAGES,
AGAIN, WHAT'S THE TAKEAWAY HERE
IF AT ANY POINT IN THE LAST 20
YEARS I HAD SAID TO YOU THAT
THERE WOULD BE TALIBAN FIGHTERS
INSPECTING U.S. HELICOPTERS
INSIDE AN EVACUATED HANGAR, HOW
IS IT ANYTHING OTHER THAN A U.S.
DEFEAT?
>> JOHN, I WOULD TELL YOU THAT
THEY CAN INSPECT ALL THEY WANT.
THEY CAN LOOK AT THEM, THEY CAN
WALK AROUND, BUT THEY CAN'T FLY
THEM.
THEY CAN'T OPERATE THEM.
WE MADE SURE TO DEMILITARIZE TO
MAKE UNUSABLE ALL THE GEAR THAT
IS AT THE AIRPORT.
ALL THE AIRCRAFT, ALL THE GROUND
VEHICLES.
THE ONLY THING WE LEFT OPERABLE
ARE A COUPLE OF FIRE TRUCKS AND
FORKLIFTS SO THAT THE AIRPORT
ITSELF CAN REMAIN MORE
OPERATIONAL GOING FORWARD.
SO I THINK WE'RE NOT OVERLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THESE IMAGES OF
THEM WALKING AROUND.
BUT, AGAIN, WE DID EVERYTHING WE
COULD TO MAKE SURE THAT
EQUIPMENT COULDN'T BE USED BY
THEM GOING FORWARD.
AND AS FOR THE DEFEAT NARRATIVE,
JOHN, HISTORIANS WILL WRITE --
THEY'LL WRITE THE CHAPTERS HERE.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT WE
PREVENTED AFGHANISTAN FROM EVER
BECOMING A SAFE HAVEN FOR AN
ATTACK ON THE UNITED STATES
AGAIN.
AND IN THE PROCESS, U.S. FORCES,
COALITION FORCES, OUR NATO
ALLIES AND AFGHAN PARTNERS MADE
A LOT OF PROGRESS IN THAT
COUNTRY, PROGRESS WHICH IS GOING
TO BE UP TO THE TALIBAN WHETHER
THEY ARE WILLING TO CONTINUE OR
NOT.
THEY HAVE MADE PROMISES AND NOW
THE UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT AND
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY ARE
GOING TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
TO THOSE PROMISES.
>> YOU SAID PREVENTED AN ATTACK
ON THE UNITED STATES FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
THERE WAS AN ATTACK ON U.S.
SERVICE MEMBERS LAST WEEK, AND
THERE ARE STILL GIVE OR TAKE 100
PLUS U.S. CITIZENS WHO WANT TO
GET OUT.
WHAT IS YOUR CURRENT ASSESSMENT
OF THE THREAT THEY MIGHT BE
UNDER?
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION THE
THREAT ENVIRONMENT IN
AFGHANISTAN REMAINS HIGH.
OBVIOUSLY WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL FOR TALIBAN
RETRIBUTION GOING FORWARD.
WE CERTAINLY -- AND WE SAW IT
OURSELVES, ARE MINDFUL OF THE
THREAT ISIS-K CONTINUES TO POSE
INSIDE AFGHANISTAN.
AS GENERAL MacKENZIE SAID
YESTERDAY, THE TALIBAN IS GOING
TO REAP WHAT THEY SEW WHEN THEY
RELEASE THESE ISIS-K PRISONERS.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE STRUGGLING
AGAINST AN ISIS-K THREAT.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS AS A
GOVERNMENT, WE'RE GOING TO STAY
MINDFUL OF OUR COMMITMENT TO THE
REMAINING AMERICAN CITIZENS AND
WE DON'T BELIEVE THERE ARE MANY,
AND AFGHAN ALLIES, TO HOLD THE
TALIBAN TO THEIR PROMISE OF SAFE
PASSAGE.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE THEIR
WORDS, BUT THEIR DEEDS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF TOOLS ACROSS
THE GOVERNMENT TO DO THAT.
>> I KNOW THAT'S THE PROMISE,
BUT PRESIDENT BIDEN AT ONE POINT
PROMISED THAT U.S. TROOPS WOULD
STAY UNTIL ALL AMERICAN CITIZENS
WHO WANTED TO GET OUT GOT OUT.
THERE ARE STILL AMERICAN
CITIZENS THERE AND U.S. TROOPS
ARE GONE.
SO IF YOU ASSESS, IF THE
MILITARY ASSESSES THAT THESE 100
PLUS AMERICANS ARE UNDER
IMMINENT THREAT, WHAT'S THE
MILITARY PREPARED TO DO ABOUT
IT?
>> OUR JOB IS TO PROVIDE OPTIONS
TO THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF, NOT
TO MAKE POLICY.
I'LL LEAVE IT RIGHT THERE, JOHN.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS WE HAVE
OTHER TOOLS AVAILABLE TO US AS A
GOVERNMENT TO HELP THE SAFE
PASSAGE OF AMERICANS GET OUT OF
THAT COUNTRY OR ANY OTHER
COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT TOTALLY UNLIKE THE WAYS
WE TRY TO MOVE AMERICAN CITIZENS
WHO ARE STRANDED OR IN DANGER OR
PERIL OUT OF OTHER COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD.
WE HAVE LOTS OF TOOLS AVAILABLE
TO US.
I DON'T FORESEE A MILITARY ROLE
AT THIS TIME.
BUT THAT'S GOING TO BE A
DECISION BY THE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS WE'RE
GOING TO REMAIN COMMITTED TO
GETTING THEM HOME AS FAST AND
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE.
THOUGH THE MILITARY MISSION HAS
ENDED, THE UNITED STATES
COMMITMENT TO THEM HAS NOT.
>> SO, WHEN PEOPLE SAY AMERICA'S
LONGEST WAR IS OVER, IS IT?
>> YES.
YES, IT IS.
THERE ARE NO AMERICAN TROOPS ANY
MORE IN AFGHANISTAN.
THE MILITARY MISSION, THE WAR
ITSELF IS OVER.
>> NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
100 AMERICANS STILL THERE?
>> JOHN, I DON'T WANT TO GET
INTO SPECULATING ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER.
WE DON'T SEE A MILITARY ROLE
HERE IN HELPING THESE LAST
INDIVIDUALS GETTING OUT, AND
OBVIOUSLY OUR JOB IS TO PROVIDE
THE PRESIDENT OPTIONS, BUT I
DON'T FORESEE THAT THAT'S AN
OPTION RIGHT NOW THAT IS GOING
TO BE NEEDED.
AGAIN, WE'RE FOCUSED ON MAKING
SURE WE MEET OUR COMMITMENT TO
THEM.
THE OTHER THING, JOHN, I'D LIKE
TO ADD IS JUST REMEMBER, 6,000
AMERICANS DID GET OUT SAFELY.
AND 123,000 OTHER PEOPLE, MOSTLY
AFGHANS, VAST MAJORITY ARE
AFGHANS.
SO WE DID MEET A MEASURE OF OUR
PROMISES AND COMMITMENTS TO
AMERICANS WHO WANTED TO GET OUT
AND TO AFGHANS WHO WANTED TO GET
OUT.
I JUST DON'T THINK THAT SHOULD
BE OVERLOOKED.
>> IT IS A REMARKABLE
ACHIEVEMENT, NO QUESTION, THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
REMOVED FROM THE COUNTRY OVER AN
INCREDIBLY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
IT IS IMPRESSIVE.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT IT COULD HAVE
BEGUN SOONER, CORRECT?
>> THERE'S GOING TO BE ALL KINDS
OF TIME TO DO THE FORENSICS ON
THIS, JOHN.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT WE
HAD BEEN PLANNING FOR
NONCOMBATANT EVACUATION
OPERATIONS ALL THE WAY BACK TO
THE SPRING, BACK TO APRIL.
IT WAS SOMETHING ON THE PLATE
AND SECRETARY AUSTIN
PRE-POSITIONED FORCES WELL
BEFORE THE TALIBAN HAD BEEN
MAKING THEIR MOVES ON THE
PROVINCIAL CAPITALS HERE IN
EARLY AUGUST, WELL BEFORE THAT.
HE DECIDED WEEKS BEFORE THAT TO
PREPOSITION FORCES IN THE REGION
IN AFGHANISTAN IN CASE WE WERE
GOING TO NEED THEM.
I WOULD REMIND EVERYONE, WE WENT
IN THE SPAN OF 48 HOURS IN MID
AUGUST.
WE WENT FROM BELIEVING WE HAD AN
AFGHAN GOVERNMENT, AN ALLY AND
PARTNER WE COULD RELY ON, AN
AFGHAN FORCES TO DEVELOP A
PRAGMATIC PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
TALIBAN TO EFFECT THESE
EVACUATIONS.
I'M NOT AT ALL DISCOUNTING OUR
CONCERN OVER THOSE THAT DIDN'T
GET OUT AND THOSE THAT ARE STILL
THERE.
WE ABSOLUTELY SHARE THAT CONCERN
AND WE'RE HEARTBROKEN WE
COULDN'T GET EVERYBODY.
BUT IN A SPAN OF LESS THAN 20
DAYS TO BE ABLE TO MOVE OUT MORE
THAN 120,000 PEOPLE SAFELY,
MOSTLY AFGHANS, I THINK IS A
REMARKABLE ACHIEVEMENT BY THE
PENTAGON AND BY OUR STATE
DEPARTMENT AND BY OUR COALITION
ALLIES, TOO.
>> I DO HAVE TO LET YOU GO.
I JUST WANT TO ASK AGAIN, BIG
PICTURE HERE, MAYBE PUT ON YOUR
OLD STATE DEPARTMENT HAT HERE AS
WELL.
AS THE WORLD LOOKS AT THIS THIS
MORNING, AS THE WORLD LOOKS AT
THIS MORNING WHERE THERE ARE NO
U.S. TROOPS IN AFGHANISTAN FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN 20 YEARS, WHAT
DO YOU THINK THE LESSON IS IN
TERMS OF AMERICAN POWER?
>> I THINK -- I DON'T KNOW THAT
I'M QUALIFIED TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION, JOHN.
I THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE A
LOT OF TIME FOR HISTORIANS AND
ACADEMICS TO WORK THEIR WAY
THROUGH THAT.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS WE'VE
LEARNED A LOT OVER THE LAST 20
YEARS AND WE'VE IMPROVED A LOT
OF OUR COUNTERTERRORISM
CAPABILITIES, INTELLIGENCE
CAPABILITIES.
THERE WAS PROGRESS MADE IN
AFGHANISTAN.
IT WILL BE UP TO THE TALIBAN TO
SEE WHAT THEY DO WITH THE
PROGRESS.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF PROGRESS
MADE.
IN THE COURSE OF 20 YEARS OF
TRYING TO PREVENT THAT PLACE
FROM EVER BEING A SAFE HAVEN
AGAIN, WE DID LEARN A LOT.
WE ACCOMPLISHED A LOT.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SEE
WHERE IT GOES FORWARD.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TAKE OUR EYE OFF THE
TERRORISM BALL.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO REMOVE THE
CAPABILITIES WE HAVE AVAILABLE